[Music]
that's a true story from your life that
sounds made up
you've got quite a few replies so this
is the one that someone sent uh to me
uh first time first time i was ever out
past 8 p.m i ran into my friend's
grandfather on my way home he warned me
about being out late saying people are
being killed out here woke up the next
morning to news that he had been
arrested for murder
next wait what
his brethren's granddad was on road yeah
and said you need to get home yeah
people are getting killed people are
getting shanked out he was out here
killing people he was out here next
morning he was arrested for murder
my grandpa said he would come back to
life only after his mum was late he died
four years back 4 p.m january the 15th
um
of a bike accident that left the scar on
his left side of his head
my kid brother was born years late at 4
pm january 15th and with the exact same
scar on the same spot of the head
nah bro this isn't what's that what's
the type of straight again
tell us a story tell us a true story
from your life that sounds made up yeah
both of these sounds
i'm pretty sure they are made up
i'm certain these are made up
i once burgled a home and stole a safe i
cracked the safe and discovered photos
of the owner molesting a child
he reported the he reported the burglary
to the police i turned the photos in the
cops called him to confess the burglary
he confessed and we both went to prison
what a
oh what a um
moral conflict yeah yeah yeah yeah what
moral conflict yes
this guy's a pedophile this should be
this should be a movie that could that
could run as much these guys are
pedophile but the only way i can prove
it is if i give myself in
i stole the safe big man
i hope i wonder if we got anything out
of it it was just pictures
probably i either turn myself in and go
pen or just let a pedophile roam the
streets
that's internal conflicts what would you
do
i think it would depend
it's tough because i think it will
depend on my um
on how much i've stolen so far
in a sense of because if i'm just out
here
burglaring yeah and i'm on like a list
i'm clearly like the next one i do when
they clock me it's lovely it's long
format yeah so if i'm on my
if i'm doing one of my last sneaky
burgles now and this is the one i grab
and i've
and they're they went like this close to
catching me last time and then i see it
i'm thinking
i don't know if i can turn myself in
i don't know
let's say
for some reason the news are spilling
all the beans okay and they're basically
saying
for whatever reason the news are saying
whoever this burglar is yeah as soon as
we catch him yeah he's doing a minimum
of six years
me being in pen you've been living as
soon as we catch him he's doing a
minimum of six years yeah and the home
boys are gonna have a play with his body
hole
they're gonna have a time with it for at
least the first six months they're gonna
have a time when we're gonna loosen that
god i've messed up so you know let's say
these pictures homeboy is in the
pictures
and there's bare use in these pictures
so you know he's snagging use
and you do your research and you find
out he's killing the use as well oh my
god so you start looking at missing
children yeah
just to double check and every missing
child is just adding up it's just
actually the pictures
it's all adding up you he's on the loose
who had
he's on the loose and he's taking and
killing kids
all right okay i'll have to i'll bail
someone i'll i'll build someone high up
yeah high up like
i can't just walk into the police
station
they wouldn't listen to what i have to
say yeah they think i'm making up story
dates
about i've got a safe and there's kids
in there yeah or kids pictures in there
with the next man yeah they think i'm
making up stories i have to bail someone
high up
high up how are you gonna get through to
this fam i don't know i'm gonna get past
the secretary i don't know james i'll
probably pay someone to take it to the
police station
that's also
risque we're gonna go ballied up
100 quid
and explain to someone who understands
you're bullied up no one's understanding
what you're saying fam i'll ballya
and just a woman
a woman has to be a woman middle-aged
woman
terrified it doesn't matter because
we're gonna take as long as it takes
this is what i'm gonna do like i'm gonna
go ballied up in a van
i'm gonna kidnap this [ __ ]
unmarked van kidnapper take her to a
field somewhere yeah and just where no
one can hear us scream yeah and just let
her get the nerves out this is black
versus yeah this is a full-blown black
bird let her get the nerves out yeah and
they're like listen are you are you done
are you dying are you done you're not in
any danger bro
but here's what happened i'm a thief i'm
a fool they're after me yeah they need
man behind bars but i'm not willing to
go
last person i t from yeah i stuck all
these pictures bro
and this guy's taking and killing
children do you understand she's gonna
black she's gonna be so conflicted as
well yeah so conflicted she'll be like
do you wanna i'll be do you understand
why you're here now i need you to go to
the police
take your phone out
and record the situations that they
believe you otherwise they might think
you're the team
get your phone out i'm pallied up
take your phone out record what you want
yeah record you need to record
and tell them bro i thiefed it
these are the pictures this is the
evidence this is the yard i'm telling
you that they are on camera right now
yeah this is where i stole it from yeah
that will be able to corroborate the
theft report yeah they will be able to
corroborate the man in the pictures is
the same guy who filed a report yeah
take it to them please
because we can't lose another kid out
here
that has to be the sure she'll do the
right thing she'd run away bro yeah i
promise you i promise you as soon as you
land she's gonna pick
going to scurry into the field pictures
are just done and she's dipping i would
i've murdered her
to god i'm [ __ ] you know
[Applause]
this [ __ ] could never do that i would
kill her
and now that's 25 for life and now i
need to find a new mole
and who's going to infiltrate the team
he's by the picture he's not picking up
pictures i get caught in the wind i'm
livid you got pictures it's safe and a
dead woman in your car [ __ ] in my van
and you're bellied up
you are going jail so the next person i
teach now needs to under fear of this
and understand what is that
listen listen
let this be a lesson to you because the
next time i speak this might be you so
shut up and hear what i have to say
story
bro i told this [ __ ] and you know what
she did she dashed the pictures of wrath
and ran
because she weren't even willing to save
kids fam are you willing to save kids i
would shake and say yes
i would shake and say yes james i'm
willing to save the children firm
imagine bro is that she a dead boy
you're just so deep
you can't get out of it now
and then imagine imagine this one now i
imagine they're like all right there
i can't
so this one they're actually like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] i can't believe it yeah i
actually can't believe it yeah yeah so
do you better use you you bread off
kidnapped believe the story he believes
the story okay he's taking the pictures
and he's like [ __ ] this guy yeah he's on
my side [ __ ] this guy and i'm like big
man thank you yeah roam free he opens
the door and jesse leaves he yanks my
body off
[Music]
and records him yes
he's dead too he has to go too
yo
you are going to all sorts of jail bro
your day has just gotten worse
i can actually imagine this being a
movie oh right all shot over one night
all right or sis the scene is one night
[ __ ]
that's how you that's how you make a
movie that ends up being do you remember
the movie phone booth
with um it had forest whitaker in it
yeah yeah colin farrell yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
ringing yes yes do not hang up this
there's a bomb in there i'm kidding
everyone listen
take the third panel to your left
lift it up take the pictures yeah
there's a parcel in there
what is it what i need you to do
fam oh oh
it's gonna be drama
that sounds like a good movie i'm not
gonna lie it sounds like a [ __ ] good
movie i'd be so livid at some point i'd
be thinking [ __ ] this yeah oh yeah and
you'd want to go home yeah you're like
these kids
these kids bro and then you think maybe
i should just murder the guy
so i mean
maybe i should just murder the guy maybe
i'm doing this a long way yeah maybe i
am justice
i am batman yeah i literally i look like
batman yeah anyway i am batman this is
how batman started because he's this you
can't trust anyone here you can't trust
anyone to do the right thing
so you have to take justice into your
own hands
i am batman literally this is had an
anti-villain origin story facts
anti-hero story anti-zero origin story
wow
[Music]
you